يعتقد ان حمى ايبولا تاتي من مناطق
الغابات مثل هذا ناقله الامراض التي تعيش
في الحيوانات الى الانسان وهذا مخيف
للغايه لان الابل قاتل سريع وحشي دموي
وفتاك فتس من عشره مصابين يموتون بسبب هذه
الحمى تبدا عوارض المرض بالظهور من يومين
الى 21 يوما بعد تعرض الشخص للفيروس وخلال
فتره الح هذا بامكان حامل الفيروس السفر
الى خارج البلاد او التنقل داخلها ولكن لا
يمكنه نشر الفيروس الا اذا تحولت العوارض
الى مرض فعلي عندما ينتشر في سوائل الجسم
ليسهل عمليه
انتشاره وعندما يصاب الشخص بهذا المرض لا
يمكنه الحراك او السفر ولكن بامكان الشخص
نشر الفيروس بعد شفائه منه بسته اسابيع
العوارض واشبه بالانفلونزا مثل الصداع
والحمى والاجهاد يضاف اليها لاحقا الاسهال
والقيء الشديد لكن اخطر العوارض هو النزيف
الدائم فعندما يمرد الشخص يتوقف تخثر الدم
والاخطر عندما يصبح النزيف داخليا مما
يؤدي الى
الموت من الصعب جدا امتحان ما اذا كان
الشخص حاملا للفيروس املا ولذلك في بدايه
انتشار رض لا يعلم الناس ما الذي يحدث
وهذا رقم مهم جدا
42 ال 42 يوما هي فترتان من الحضانه واذا
اكتمل اليوم الاني من دون ظهور حالات
جديده فهذا يعني نهايه فتره انتشار
المرض